we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 I want to go to our caller from
Isaac's 1 2 area code
caller from 6 1 2 waiting where are you
calling from hey David it's Chris from
New York live from the epicenter how you
doing good how are you not too bad
so over the last couple days we've all
been seeing the people the spring
breakers like doing the you know very
embarrassingly reckless news conferences
like them not caring about you know
spreading the diseases and I remember
you said it's like their faces are oh
they look puffy and burned but some of
them did yes some of them believe
they're priceless it was weird the
spring breakers their faces were all
like bruised and burned while they were
they were giving the press conferences
which didn't suggest to me that they
were the best people to go to for advice
on self-preservation
yeah the one bro with like the backwards
hat in the summer and face yeah but um
my question was basically during the
AIDS epidemic I know people are getting
prosecuted for knowingly spreading a
disease right could you see a world
where during this coronavirus epidemic
people do end up going to prison for
knowingly spreading the epidemic well
listen i think that it's completely
impossible that that's going to happen
for someone who's just like at the beach
you know I just don't see that I do
believe that if a governor issues an
order of nothing over 20 people and
you've got 200 people at a concert
someone should pay the price for that
now I don't know if it's the venue if
it's the individuals who go if it's
every I don't know what the answer is to
that but if you've got a governor with
it with something that says no no events
over a certain amount there probably
should be some consequence to that now
let me take it a step further though we
now have reports that teenagers are
finding it funny to go to grocery stores
and cough on produce right the idea
being maybe they've got coronavirus and
they're putting it on your apples if
they COFF on it or whatever right and I
actually think there's a guy in London
the kids they're spitting on old ladies
saying they have coronavirus right
obviously that's like spitting on
someone is already at least in the US
and a rest able offense coughing on
produce there's probably some statute
that says that that's oh so we've got it
just in for
that stuff right because I mean I could
see a world where people start getting a
real black-tailed sense of nihilism and
they get coronavirus and they go out and
they knowingly want to infect people and
yeah you know in your world let's say
David is that the the you're the doj
right like if you know people are doing
this like what is the sentence for these
people I don't really I don't know what
the sentence is but certainly if you
found out that someone had tested
positive and was violating a quarantine
and was going around coughing and
spitting on people obviously the
spitting is already a criminal and
you've got to figure out what is the
additional thing you know what are you
there must be I'm sure there is some law
that could be thrown at them that
already exists that would apply to what
they're doing may I sure hope so because
I mean it's looking like people are
taking it more seriously but again I
just wish people would really hunker
down and stop being reckless I agree
with you and that's why you know Trump
now talking about letting her rip and
filling churches on Easter seems like a
very dangerous thing to be talking about
oh my god he went on that diatribe he's
like the church's they're gonna be so
full it's gonna be so beautiful yeah
just making me think of fili in 1918
when they had that big bon parade it's
it's absolutely crazy to be thinking
about it and you know hopefully somebody
will talk him out of it soon I sure
helps out well thank you David alright
my friend thank you great to hear from
you appreciate it